[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pigskins take on conference rival arm I
do hi this Friday and the first round of
the playoffs
you know Coach Walker's got those boys
practicing hard to make sure they're
ready for war do you think that'll get
us somehow silenced no but this will go
[Music]
hey y'all doing this ain't no circus
show this is a football two hands always
use two hands why are you here practice
ended an hour ago
and this is my house why is this town
always watching us practice it's 6:00
p.m. on a Tuesday
don't you have families 61 hours until a
big game against the armadillo hi
armadillos
it's like Christmas II set more
religious yeah the library needs my help
are you someone's mom not yet cubed not
yet who needs to be adopted she's doing
that thing from The Blind Side come with
me no you are a stranger and adoption is
a long legal process with lots of
paperwork
looks like you can teach me just as much
as I can teach you boys bring it in I
think this lady at the gas station we
may be from different worlds but we're
all still huge
[Music]
what is wrong with this town I can
inspire you